thing up
um sam jay
sam jay
is having season two of pause
her show on hbo max
um
which i had always heard about i had
seen some clips but i hadn't actually
sat down and watched it until
you told me
i think it's worth watching and then we
can talk about it and i totally agree um
as a white person it was very
uncomfortable
and
as it should have been you know we
deserve to be uncomfortable but
beyond just the topic she tackles i
think just the overall format of the
show is super
unique as well yeah yeah it's very
unique it's very different and i think
like
i mean when you talk about just a
different point of view sam j has a very
different point of view in how she
tackles topics
but her writing is so impeccable
and like the amount of details that she
goes into like there's such nuances like
even in watching her special her
special's actually really solid too
watching her special
the way she talks about different types
of topics
is very nuanced but it's very funny and
intelligent and that's what i really
like about sanjay
yeah
yeah that's i think that's a big reason
why you know she got picked up for
season two is because like on the
surface like you may be like oh it's
people talking about like you know
important topics but like it's coming
from such a unique point of view that i
me as as like a comedian but also as a
white person that would like to be a
better white person you know um
i think i think it does a lot beyond
just like tackling dope issues that we
need to talk about but also does it in a
super unique way
that's like part podcast part like
interview interview part man on the
street part sketch like there's so many
different elements that she brings into
it
that um
is really inspiring for comedians of
what they want to create and maybe how
they can start to
rethink the traditional format of like a
a show
yeah you know my favorite part like i
know this is a very small little nuance
thing
i love the fact that sam j has so many
comics
in her show
like it's nothing but comedians in her
show
and then they all get that hbo credit
yes
i mean and some of them are just like
sitting and chilling and it's like yep i
was on hbo like that right
that's just such a killer like
small little move but like it's almost
like you're building people up to be
like yeah i was on hbo i was on the
episode of sam j pause um but it's like
that's just a cool little like
nugget of
kind of helping people out that i think
it's very dope for comedians to do yeah
i agree and that's that's what we try to
do as well here is like you know
give comics they shine and give them
opportunities where they may otherwise
not get them and it's cool to see
someone at her level doing the same
thing as well absolutely yeah yeah it's
very cool because i've seen like tons of
atlanta comics on there
like you know uh but it's just great i
think that's just that's just the dopest
thing and now they get that credit
yeah so check that out it comes out on
may 20th
um when i went to the other screen to be
fancy our timer reset so um but i i
think that was about five minutes um
yeah so check it out
so check out sam jay's
yeah season two of paws it's all on
uh hbo max
awesome all right